well I'm joined Now by Douglas Murray
who's on the Gaza border Douglas let me
ask you first of all why have you felt
the need to go
there well I've covered every Israeli
conflict since the 2006 Lebanon war uh
I've covered lots of other conflicts as
well and this one is obviously an
incredibly important conflict it's one
that is going to be crucial not just for
Israel but for the region and I like to
see these things firsthand as you know
appears I do and I've I've read your
stuff for many years about these uh kind
of uh conflicts let me ask you what is
your what's your feeling on the ground
there I know you've been with some of
the IDF what is your feeling about the
motivation for this uh war from the
Israeli side is it revenge is it
something different what what are you
picking
up well it's not Revenge I mean I think
the most obvious thing is I spent part
of today at the uh kibutz of near Oz
this is a buts right down the road from
here by the Gaza border where there were
about 400 residents uh 80 of them were
kidnapped on the 7th of October and
another 30 to 40 were murdered and we
went through I went through the remains
of their houses uh saw all the blood
spattered walls and uh went through the
charred remains of that Village that
Community uh that was just one of the
massacre sites I went earlier past the
massacre site of what you remember was
there was the music festival uh also
near the the Gaza border uh which was
taking place where so many hundreds of
young people were having a rave and then
were massacred uh raped uh mutilated and
again kidnapped and taken through
through the border into Gaza so uh you
see the remnants of that appalling day
everywhere around here it's very hard to
find a family anywhere in Israel it
hasn't been directly or you know very
closely related to the atrocity of that
day you know 1,400 civilians slaughtered
in one day and thousands more injured is
the sort of thing that that will have an
effect on any society it would be
roughly comparative to say 20,000 people
being killed in our own country um so
it's it's a massive thing it's a massive
blow uh in Israel the whole nation has
felt it and of course people know that
there needs to be an answer to this and
I think that's well you can hear behind
me as I'm speaking some of that answer
the Crump of artillery shells and uh uh
uh missiles from the air it seems and
you can see some of that rising over the
Border behind me you've talked about
proportionality in this conflict being
absurd I've talked a lot about what is
proportionate and I I struggled to think
of what a proportionate response is to
the barbarism of those Terror attacks um
you know there is a view and maybe you
share this view but there is a view I
think Ben Shapiro said this to me when I
interviewed him that there there should
be no limit on the response that Israel
has it's not about proportion it's not
about you kill one of us we call one of
you this is about a war specifically
designed to eliminate Hamas and they
will do what it takes
yes well I mean remember the one of the
heads of hamz said only a few days ago
uh uh from uh the comfort of his foreign
residents because remember the heads of
hamz don't live among their peoples they
uh they've been made billionaires by
taking an international aid for years
now uh but one of the heads of hamz said
uh the other day we will keep doing
October the 7th again and again and
again so there's a realization in Israel
I think that this is just unlivable you
you you can't have a situation where you
have a neighbor who well won the
election in 2006 after Israel withdrew
from the Gaza promptly killed their
fellow Palestinians the Fatar members in
the Gaza threw them off buildings and
shot them in the back
uh um so Hamas has been ruling Gaza for
all the last one and half decades uh it
has spent all the international Aid
money and much more that has come into
it on its own infrastructure of Terror
tunnels its infrastructure of rockets
and other Munitions to throw at Israel
and then of course in enriching its
leaders the place you see behind me
could be Singapore by now and there's a
reason it isn't and it's the leadership
of Hamas and so you know I think that it
is something that people have to realize
that this is not a situation which is
sustainable for Israel and yes the
Israeli uh government is going to be
doing whatever it needs to do to fulfill
its objective of of ridding uh the Gaza
of Hamas uh how easy or difficult a job
that is is another question but uh it's
something that is going on as we speak
but in terms of the the moral quandry
which I've been feeling and it's not
about Israel wanting to eliminate Hamas
I completely agree with that mission
statement and certainly there's no
chance of any peace when you have a
terror group in charge of Gaza in the
way that they've now completely
established themselves to be with no
limits and just a desire to eradicate
Israel and as many Jewish people as they
can kill so just park that to one side I
concur with the mission statement but it
is incredibly difficult just on a human
level to see because we know the
civilian population in Gaza is half
children to see the sheer number
of kids who are being killed by the
Israeli Onslaught that's come back
against toas what do you feel about that
on a human level what should we all be
feeling about that the first thing is
the first thing is should those deaths
really be attributed to the Israeli side
um we saw the other day the BBC and
other media uh reported that the people
who were lying dead on the street and
one of the main routs through Gaza was
alleged to to be
a um a massacre carried out by Israelis
it turned out wasn't the case at all uh
it was hamz massacring Palestinians
fleeing South as the Israelis had
recommended they do um so the question
in a way that you ask I would say
there's an answer to which is who
exactly is responsible for these deaths
um if you do as hamaz does uh decide to
uh build bunkers and put rockets on them
and then put hospitals on top of them
who exactly is responsible for that uh
is it the Israelis in their response or
is it Hamas for doing that uh if you do
decide as Hamas has done uh to use all
of these billions of dollars of
international Aid to build tunnels where
you can hide uh among other things the
the kidnapped uh Israelis um who's
responsible for for the the strikes that
happen as a result and any civilian
deaths is it the Israelis or is it Hamas
who has been holding the Palestinian
peoples of the Gaza hostage for the last
15 years and more again I repeat this
point you know a lot of what has been
said about this seems to suggest that
Hamas has no responsibility for this you
know if you if if you went into your
neighbor's house ransacked it raped your
neighbors uh killed some of them took
others into captivity and then somebody
said uh that's not on uh I'm going to do
something in retaliation to that uh you
would bear the cost of that you'd bear
the price for that there is Ries have
the right to respond uh to such an
atrocity and I'm I'm rather surprised or
at least I'm I'm not surprised in a way
I'm disappointed as ever by the number
of commentators in the UK and elsewhere
who seem to who always use times like
this to say things like we've got a
we've got to you know this is a time for
judicious voices this is a time for calm
and much more I do always wonder if
those people would say the same or feel
the same if it was a bit closer to their
own home you know if it wasn't a Kuts
down the road uh like the one I was in
earlier that had been attacked but um
you know Village after Village in the
south of England uh I don't think we'd
be hearing those same voices I think
there's a very particular standard that
the Israelis are held to I think it's an
unfair standard it's an unequal standard
it's an intolerable standard for the
Israelis but when people say you know
you've just got to sort of live with
this uh the Israelis quite rightly will
be saying well we don't see quite why we
do the comparison between Hamas and the
NIS is insufficient and I sorry there's
a
incoming uh incoming
what about this issue around the pro
Palestinian marches and specifically the
one plan for armus to stay here in
London on Saturday do you think it
should go
ahead well uh my own view is that it
shouldn't and it shouldn't because it's
not because it should be banned but
because it's a grotesque insult to the
British people
uh it's a deliberately provocative day
to choose for such a March it's a
deliberately provocative March as the
telegraph showed just yesterday around
half of the organizers of the March are
themselves linked with Hamas uh which
isn't at all surprising we have hamaz
commanders after all who live in London
very safely often on welfare um and uh
so yes I think it's an intolerable March
it's intolerable provocation to the
British public and the British
government and the British police by the
way who Saturday after Saturday have
been made put up with unbelievable
taunting and abuse uh from the Marchers
uh it's clearly it's it's very clear by
now appears that what is happening is
that every week the the crowds are
pushing and seeing if they can push the
police further and further harder and
harder and be more and more provocative
and they're managing to do that uh but
this is culminating this weekend and
here here's the thing I don't think and
I certainly read and hear that large
numbers of the British public are just
not going to put up with this uh that
let me pick you up on that diverted away
from whiteall right but let me pick you
up on that because it's interesting
because you like me have been very vocal
you know and passionate defender of free
speech and we know that that includes
sure that you have to accept that other
people you may vly disagree with have a
right to free speech you know
Christopher Hitchin someone that you and
I both admire this isn't this no I'm
going to come to my question but
Christopher Hitchin said the only thing
that should be upheld at all casts and
without qualification is a right of free
expression because if that goes then so
do all other claims of right as well now
what was interesting to me I've been on
a bit of a journey this week about what
I really think about this and Nicholas
SS actually said something that really
made me sit up and take notice and
changed my mind about it actually
because he's Churchill's grandson he's a
conservative um and he said strongly
yesterday that he thinks the March
should be allowed to go ahead because
the very freedoms that the people on
Armes day who we honor who gave their
lives uh in the wars they did so to
preserve the freedoms of people like
those Marchers the ones who are not
being violent the ones who are not
showing proam stuff that they have a
right to to
protest well well we we we'll try to
single those two things out for a second
uh first of all I don't regard Nicholas
SS as a sort of hereditary uh uh
inheritor of the mantle of Churchill
just because he happens to be his
grandson um uh besides what you quoted
from Christopher earlier he would never
have uh said that that right extended to
supporting Terror groups I mean we're in
a total quandry in the UK as you know
and it's a Despicable quandry to be in
we host them as Leaders we have a deputy
prime minister former deputy prime
minister of Iran living in Harrow we've
been at the center of allowing these
people to be in our country and indeed
to plot Terror from our country for
years so it's always a bit Rich to hear
the British I think uh lecturing others
about being an unsound part of of the
International Security uh Community as
for the actual marches look um I'm
afraid that the rules on this are very
very clear um you are not allowed to
glorify Terror or call for Terror on the
streets of Britain and that existed
before the 2006 terrorism act baned
glorification and it certainly exists
now uh if you stand on the Streets of
London Calling for Jihad you are calling
for Terror and that is actually a place
where free speech is at its limit and is
no longer permissible it's the say with
for instance calls for in on the London
tubes remember we had a touch of in on
the London tubes a few years ago so
again calling for in father is something
that you're not allowed to do in the UK
murder you're not allow you're not
allowed to let me finish one other case
you're not allowed uh to stand on the
Streets of London and call for the
murder of Jews or any other minority and
yet people have been getting away with
thisday after Saturday and and are the
police arresting people no no they're
not the police last week said we're
outnumbered right so so that is a key
point the police have said met
commissioner samart roley said the laws
created by parliament are clear there is
Absol no absolute power to ban protest
therefore there will be a protest this
weekend but the laws are also there to
stop people brazenly supporting
terrorism so if people were to use a
pramas banner or chant pramas uh
sentiment that would be against the
current law of this country and the
police should take action that's a
different issue though it is it is but
it's not being police it's not being
police I understand so on that I can
agree with you the police need to
enforce the existing laws however there
will be a li they're not going to
because they're outnumbers they're out
you and I can agree that that that's
wrong but that shouldn't mitigate the
rights well don't you think that matters
hang on don't you think that matters no
it does matter that means that we have a
rule of law but it's not able to be
policed what's the point of having a law
if you can't police it well I agree with
you but I also think that the the there
are a large number of those protesters
who genuinely are are in their eyes
protesting for peace and they're Pro
Palestinian and they have a view in the
way well I disagree with that I disagree
with that and I'll tell you one reason
why the crowds in question are 100 times
larger than the number of people who
came out when hundreds of thousands of
people were being killed in Yemen they
are a hundred times larger than the
number of people who came out when
Bashar al- Assad killed hundreds of
thousands of people in Syria seems to me
that the people in question only care if
one side
in the particular conflict happens to
involve the Israelis very excited but
they're allowed to so I don't well
they're allowed to absolutely and and we
can make judgments about them but I
would not presume by any means that what
you're talking about a pro peace people
they're anti-israeli that's it well but
they're allowed to be anti-israeli I
think that's the point they're not allow
sure they're allowed to be if you
allowed to be in that case I suppose we
have to allow people to be anti- other
nations as well I mean Britain was
founded at the same sorry Israel sorry
was founded in the same year within the
year of Pakistan maybe we should allow
large protests of hundreds of thousands
of people to go around the Streets of
London protesting that Pakistan doesn't
have the right to exist or right to
defend itself maybe we should I don't
think it's a good a good president what
hang on I don't think you have a right
to say that Israel doesn't exist if you
want the extermination of all people in
Israel that is that is a criminal
offense however if you are literally as
I said well it doesn't seem to be a
criminal offense P it doesn't you and I
can agree on that clearly in a position
we're clearly in a position where
they're not police the law otherwise we
wouldn't have all of these videos of
people inciting violence on the streets
but Douglas you and I can agree that the
police need to enforce existing law I I
don't there's no dispute between us on
that and they should be doing that a lot
more but we also I think have to surely
look at the people who are genuinely
there in a nonviolent manner of which
there are many these are massive
protests I think back to the protest for
example against Donald Trump when he
came to London against America because
he was the president we allowed that to
happen I didn't necessar neily agree
with them but we allowed them to happen
you know I remember Madonna saying we
should blow up the White House a woman's
March in Washington that happened and
people accepted that yeah but yeah but
here's here's here's a very important
point on that Pi Madonna almost
certainly so far as I know has no
military capability behind her so when
Madonna says I'd like to blow up the
White House it's a piece of stupid
rhetoric uh from a pop star um when
you've just had the largest Massacre of
Jews since the Holocaust and you have
Hamas supporters and others marching
through London Calling for it to happen
again that does matter because there is
a capability so there is a difference
isn't there well there is but I don't
think that all of these protesters are
pramas and the difference the difference
is whether you have a large artillery
behind but you wouldn't you don't
honestly think they're all pramas these
people well I I I think that anyone who
for instance chants things like from the
river to the sea is is in fact yes but
they're not all doing that or is
criminally ignorant oh well they are I
mean there's masses of videos of them
marching past West winst Abby last week
saying exactly that but they're not
alling past s Winston Church watch the
videos and there are lots of people and
some who aren well here's a challenge
okay well here's a challenge Piers if
you decided to go on some kind of March
and in week one you discovered that you
had the BNP along your side calling for
instance for the murder of all black
people would you not wonder whether or
not you should go on week two and would
you not drop out by about week three I'd
have thought so I would
that's a good question uh and yes I
would but that doesn't actually that
should right so we can tell something
about the Marchers well you can tell
that you can say that you have a view
your own opinion is they shouldn't be
marching alongside these other people
however they are still entitled in a
free Democratic country like us look I I
don't have absolute opinions on this I I
just think it's a really interesting
test of how far Free Speech goes and I
do feel un interesting test if I could
say so sure the the interesting test if
I can say so Pi is there are limits to
this in fact you are not allowed to
glorify the murder of people on the
streets of Britain you are not allowed
to be a member of a prescribed terrorist
group in Britain but I return to the
point I made at the start we allow it I
repeat we have Hamas commanders living
in the UK who take welfare in the UK and
use it to commit Terror why are they not
locked up because we have laws
that we don't pursue yeah we have
criminal charges that we don't use the
person in particular I'm thinking of
Muhammad saala got British citizenship
you're meant to sign a form saying
you're a person of good character to
become a British citizen can you say
that somebody who was a former military
commander of ham in the West Bank is
quote a person of good character I'd say
not so again like the police like many
other people the border control in the
UK doesn't enforce the law doesn't care
to do so and I repeat there is a serious
problem with this in the UK Israel as
you can see tonight can look after
itself I wonder if Britain can say the
same yeah listen I understand that point
you've also said it will have to be
counted if the March goes ahead because
the British public shouldn't have to put
up with it but what does that mean in
reality you're not endorsing people to
go and confront them are you no no not
at all um I'm I would suggest that if
the Senate half for instance comes under
attack there should be a peaceful ring
of people around the Senate half to
protect Ed as with other monuments and I
think that that's what many people will
do I hope they do so peacefully but as
this goes on and as the pro provocations
grow and grow I'm afraid I'm very very
afraid from what's going to happen this
weekend coming in the UK personally I
think it's safer in Israel these days
than it is in central London certainly
for
Jews let's talk um given you're over
there right now uh what what concerns me
about what Israel is doing is not their
efforts to get rid of Hamas but because
of the particular IC nature of Hamas
embedded themselves among civilian
populations with the masses amounts of
Civilian casualties that will inevitably
come and that figure will grow and grow
and grow are we not as Barack Obama
warned are we not creating here uh just
an opportunity for far greater
radicalization of all those young
Palestinians who watch their loved ones
get killed why would we imagine that at
the end of all this they're going to
want to do anything other than to become
a new of Hamas in wanting to exact
revenge for what happened to their
families well two things one is if you
just follow the logic of what Barack
Obama said then you just shouldn't do
anything uh if you're Israel you should
be attacked and just sit back and say
great we'll wait for the next one um but
the second and more important thing is
your question supposes that there is a
sort of peaceful Palestinian population
in the Gaza who would love a two-state
solution and then a few bad apples in
hamz I think that's not true why is it
that when uh one of the victims of the
music festival a poor young German
Jewish girl uh who it seems was was
raped and then uh brutally uh murdered
and taken into the Gaza naked why was it
that you can find and anyone can find
this online uh a crowd of ordinary gazin
it wasn't hamz it wasn't a Hamas rally
ordinary gazin uh uh spitting on her
body uh hitting her body mutilating her
body further as it went down a Street
does that strike you peers as a Placid
population of pecnik types who are just
desperately waiting for a two-state
solution to be put back on the table for
the millionth time in the last 70s
something years it doesn't seem like
that to me no but there are over two
million people in Gaza and there weren't
two million people in that video clip
there were a few hundred so I I don't
like to make yeah a few hundred at
random a few hundred at random and did
you see anyone in it saying hey guys
stop we're not meant to mutilate the
bodies of of of girls or rape them in
public no I didn't see that but but then
what you're really articulating correct
me if I'm wrong here but isn't what
you're articulating really an
endorsement of collective punishment
where you assume they're all guilty no
and if they don't stand up to Hass
they're also guilty and and that's where
people have a problem I think with the
moral line here which is if you hold if
you hold all the Garin equally
responsible then is that not Collective
punishment which is illegal well first
of all first of all um there are there
is some respons possibility for peoples
in the Gaza um if you elect elect Hamas
and uh and they kill fata and then they
remain in power for all of the years
afterwards um I'm afraid that there is
some uh responsibility of the people in
that situation you know when the Germans
uh um had Adolf Hitler come to power and
voted for him uh we in Britain took the
view that the German people were
responsible in some way so I'm not for
Collective punishment per se but nor am
I for this idea that there is something
unique going on in the Israeli Gaza
context that we and Britain couldn't
understand UN in our own history done
very similar things but there is one
unique thing which is that the
population of Gaza is pretty unique and
that nearly half of the population are
children that is a unique situation no
I'll tell you what's unique about the
population of Gaza it's the only
population in the world where people
routinely claim Israelis are committing
genocide but which has a population boom
all of the time I mean that strikes me
as being quite an interesting thing
about the Gaza
um but as for as for the moraly I want
to make a very very important point if I
can say so on this which is you know
people quite often abuse history and
they say things all the time right about
the only thing anyone from history knows
is about the Nazis here's something I
can tell you with absolute certainty uh
peers having not just seen some of the
results of what Hamas did on the ground
here in Israel a few weeks ago but
having watched the videos of the
unedited footage uh which I was one of
the journalists um sadly allowed to see
the other day I can tell you one thing
thing the comparison between Hamas and
the Nazis is insufficient and I sorry
there's an
incoming uh
incoming get safe
Douglas come
come
are you okay
Douglas it came from the other direction
so okay anyhow we're okay are you okay
um let's let's just yeah yeah yeah fine
sorry it was it was a it was a rocket
coming it looked like it was just going
to land on us here which way was that
rocket coming from is it coming from
Gaza or from
Israel yes seem to be coming from Gaza
so yeah it's fine it's okay it's been
happening all day um let me just fin
before we go on Douglas Atman how does
that make you how does that make you
feel what just happened
there I mean it's uh I'm I'm a little
used to it I was in Ukraine last year
and was in Kon and Odessa and mikol and
when the Russians were shelling it so
I'm a little used to it
um uh but just if I can just finish this
point you know this so there's a lot of
banging going on but anyway we'll keep
going um well if you need if you need to
stop Doug we understand no no don't
worry if we need to stop I'll I'll I'll
run to the shelter I show you um the the
thing that struck me you know appears
about seeing the 7th of October footage
was that but
um even the Nazis were actually ashamed
of what they did you know SS battalions
who spent their days shooting Jews in
the back of the head and pushing them
into TR uh into trenches had to get very
very drunk in the evening to uh uh
forget what they had done uh the Nazi
High command famously had to sort of get
around the problem of soldier morale
because the soldiers knew this was n
exactly what their lives were meant to
look like either I tell you one very big
difference if you look at the footage
the raw footage and I really hope people
don't on a wider scale have to view what
I viewed the other day um if they see it
they will see something that is at least
as barbaric as what the Nazis did but
here's the difference they did it with
Glee they were deeply proud you see
people um uh trying you know taking the
head off a young Israeli man with a
shovel and then uh calling their parents
back in Gaza and telling them Father
father I've killed two Jews with my 10
10 Jews with my own hands get mother on
the phone I want to show tell her how
great a job her son has done you know I
I come back to this thing I'm not
exaggerating this it's very very
interesting and people need to realize
you had this situation with uh with the
Nazis where they also were a genocidal
anti-semitic organization but they tried
to cover their crimes up hamas's
actually proud of them and they've said
they will do them until the whole world
is clear clear of Jews yeah so I suggest
we take that seriously and I think that
Israel is taking it seriously I hope
they continue to take it seriously but I
think the world should take it seriously
and that includes Britain and when I
hear British journalists British
commentators and British politicians
lecturing the Israelis on what they
should do I think I'm sorry this shows a
failing in our country it shows that we
in Britain cannot enforce our laws we
don't even enforce our borders in
Britain it's us that is the weak Link in
the International Security chain on this
not Israel Douglas how does this war end
Netanyahu said yesterday that he sees
the at the end of this uh Gaza falling
under Israel occupation for an
indefinite period now there are many
people in Israel who absolutely want
Netanyahu out and hold him accountable
for what happened on October the 7th in
this terms of the failing of Defense
security he's deeply unpopular now
amongst his own people but this whole
idea that you somehow reconcile the 75e
conflict which is blown up into Warfare
Time and Time Again by Israel ending up
as a completely occupying force that
seems to me utterly untenable
yeah well I I think that I mean look
this is it's too early to tell I would
just say this and I've said this before
but Israel is one of the only countries
in the world that's never allowed to win
a conflict uh it has been left with this
question of the Palestinians in the West
Bank the question of the Palestinians in
Gaza it's been left with this for years
and by the way I say left with it
because remember the jordanians could
solve the problem in the West Bank
immediately by taking the Palestinians
there in or taking some kind of control
they don't want to the the Egyptians I
have friends who were born in Gaza when
it was owned by the Egyptians run by the
Egyptians the Egyptians could solve the
Gaza problem tomorrow by allowing the
gazans into Egypt or taking control of
the Gaza themselves nobody wants the
Palestinians people and there's this
endless endless mistake that is being
made and it has been made all my
lifetime certainly which is that there's
this unsolved problem but it it is the
job of the Israelis to solve it what is
happening behind me is a demonstration
of the fact that it is an insoluble
problem that the Israelis keep being
told to solve Gaza ever since the
Israelis left it in 2005 could have
become Singapore it could have become a
thriving place but ham didn't want that
they wanted to turn it into a place
instead of building upwards they built
downwards instead of building a great
buildings they buil built great tunnels
this is a tragedy for the Palestinian
peoples but it's one that has been
brought on them by groups like Hamas who
do not want a settlement in this war
Douglas Murray uh so powerful to talk to
you there on the Gaza border and I'm
glad that you came through what was a
pretty scary moment in the middle of
that interview and I appreciate you
coming back and continuing interview as
if nothing had happened quite remarkable
to witness after say from the safety of
my my London Studio but I do appreciate
it and stay safe out there right right
we do very good to see you peers thanks
doas